die übung rx 2018 ist die größte übung
der luftstreitkräfte in diesem jahr
[Musik]
am 21 22 märz 2018 trainierten die
soldaten die evakuierung von personen
mit als lufttransport die übung fand im
raum wien und niederösterreich statt und
dient der vorbereitung auf den
österreichischen eu ratsvorsitz in der
zweiten jahreshälfte 2008
[Musik]
die herausforderung also eine übung
einer evakuierung ist es dass wir eine
große anzahl an luftfahrzeugen wir
sprechen hier von 12 hubschraubern die
im gleichen raum operieren
gemeinsam mit chats und flächen fliegern
dass wir diese große anzahl an
luftfahrzeugen koordinieren dass sie das
entsprechend vorbereiten
jeder seine rolle kennt jeder weiß was
ja in welcher situation tun muss und mal
so dann dieses drehbuch mit allen
eventualitäten ablaufen zu lassen
[Musik]